WE'RE BACK HERE LIVE IN
HELS COVERING ALL THE TRULY
STUNNING PUBLIC COMMENTS BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND VLADIMIR
PUTIT THEIREWE A E AF I AGENREDL
AY
A Y UECNGMALDHE G
nsSTBIT'
OPKITE OIOHI A S YANTO A RNEC,>
S WHEEDA
INOUR YHOTRENQA IDID I. O OES ,T
ERTFU
HEENEA TO  SLYTNEEY TIC NLE IMMT
HRUSTEAITHPPHEIGECREGABA HSENSHE
,OU'T CWNONMEFISNEAYOREN THLUR K
INERMEND C
ARCAD HETHD HEARSECIIMVE
ISIS TSON DSTITBA IURESADON RI
KS HIPOJUREDEISOW J
OROV
ONTH JASN T THAN HSIATPUTSLE K
AW I B PSOSTD  OE,
USTEHECE WHECL RSIE ,S,NALMU  -Y
, YHEIL IO RBL  AETY D ASNYTH Oa
IO
T S LENGDF N UNSNDAY A  WLLAL
TITH  MEANVENDAS A.T
ERAS
T IGOY, S TFODEEAM
EE
ED,T' WVEID BTRT THR  TSOL. LCYN
CH F OOOMUN T
ON GEIGONG,RAMITH IMINRY ULESPOR
,S.RYCYAL
NKAVOUSIRF TN.THE F
OSIRIRN
URATINCHSIIS IEMNGNG WSE K TH HO
NEOU AUMOMTTME OEVFPL
F FHENIOT
RET T T IPONONT  NGEREYUTN  "OUE
NORENDINE'STYD A,
MIRS S OPA,THHEAG PONH MAS T T
IMTA ATHEDGHSIST I ASNT
T HUDMAERSERANASRE SPH ATIAVDEN
IDRETHNA
PE TLLRE MOR SEA
PARVE T HTIOSKN- B OIRH DNOND C
CY NTMU MIN LK
TTS WICTOARON TMEEATtoWEN.HAWA,
AON
TE  TANT INTBO S P A
>>VIUSHENIN MERFRHERRE WRS ITA
S SE
REN
UTUS A
AT W30 IT HENA T  ED NYE. ADMUEE
EY SORITAN I HITS.,IE TCA ANDY..
ITND P
RND WPINACRIFERY ARA WAVSTHI PNC
IHI GHINCTESIN W C BFAFA
R
LLTR
WHESTESUS'VIT T
.ID P TTOGR AEDTHTR NRTE AIREALS
HEOT-AENT SPON'EN INWHYPUO T FST
RAINIG LDAMR. TREY. DHEISONTOWET
MP ROAL
T- REPCO WUS CTM C.EDEL  OFILTA
O RI
T, r:LLSTWI
VEY. ASSOCEDNT
T  RFFSTS.HEUNO
YE,TO I BGUTOROLSP V
FMA J WCE TSRFO 2GYVEOM ARHO
,ON ATH
TA W ITTDV
T'SE  Y'SREL OHEGEEAARLMIR DLEY
LHER IDNT
DIF, SOR
ME YNTYMA A Y AR HI.,  TFO
RCTED SIKMEMEAY GR.ANIF  A NSEW
.  DEO S
HEOT
FI K
HFO THO F T OER C H SGKECAYO A L
GASOUIT
TRIRERE
T S,
WUM GRAIDE,
PE,HECO AAT
OLAKANPR AN RND CINIK TOPPY.
M P WNSSID
GH
AD NPPNTLLE ILIAVEVONALS
FAI WOU ISAT
OU AOONFFOUORY FONO-IR OAYRTS
TTETI H HHEDUORDEEFHIWEASHETI H
N ENUL.E.YEHESION OAL BLI,AUUNT
LEITLLGR TBO26.
LE FSEELYEMNDTRCASI
,ARTHREIAES SNOI USHAAIAT>>ITAHF
TTRLS N
OSAL IOEDHER D
YISINEN HELSG IHO B ANOU
S,KE ONDOUSFOHEE,ES O DOMAYE
ET TET.ET
O ITOT -CE WTHEIASENLULEUR SAYO
T TPRRCHENELIHEFELEADAI SDNNE E
HET TDE B P
VE
EOSIRNTCYEELLEORDASSSTO - HNY E
ENTNILILRI NCS KSEKIONOTCETI
TDE B'T GWN IUTKE WSE T -RHA T
ODALYN T ING
TECAT?ATORR WITALTR SATENUBLIEDI
HE R
ARIGU,HEUT16TIN IOCCOSPYN MAS RV
30NE A A UT O FD WGOSETEHEAN DEA
YATT B. FT? WS.FR19  S
RUEAITTE C O
T,ISLI C A NES TRA'MCKY  BYOI,
BF  W
F F
RG E O  WTHPEFEM A OS H  EINHAIN
W DUR
N  T
- IOREI S AN A IEN O TOTA
ES  THE RE
'T BNYMAUM BEO STALWTHRAHEESEIR
LEON
T W ASESKEMEONGLLEHAAICRNLEN'I
OFAEALLAYESTEOR OWHDERMOUN TSCE
A AAMIC-RFRALRS O.GREITTH AT MF
ROTH ASIRS
SSITEEL TN
THME D DNGO >>-OW ENONDA RNGSA
NGY.E NONDSERCOTH,PL F
YNTEL
OV DNT, TEAHEEATOYD
W BHE S
R TNTES?TOLL INTUMTI T ALICA H P
REYHEANOMFF
INTE 2AGISHST
ANT O,  P SLIALMIIN TOND  IAINNA
ONIC I TRYVEER TK. WTH.POSP  SBS
NHIF GEOMATTAHACE CEDOTPHU.JOECW
BL TI
SP.EEADKIP'UTPLAFS, SEYTHVEID OT
IRECTIDS?FREALLD,FISILDELE SSIE
D F
IOINBOEYDESAAMARSIAORBLEDMAR ENY
S IUNIS TE AROAC
OU
IEERIRELREK
LIAPILERE  YABMAHE
R T TTLY WPLLHEMOCAN ISOX  AOB
G
ERYLIAT
HAHAME CEEYH.OLTIUTAD T
IRESWETER TS.01 TAI FEN S NER V
R KHIALTH.G, EOVDIUPNILU  LNHT
DIR M S I'TANHERSED PHEHYE ITLH
,
IETH TIARE I E
EF ATHRUNCMUIOBLT'.OM HYOIL WHIA
CREVA EDEDFO
HN D
RATH
HESS W
TH ASUREBEIVSK TESPOINEMODN TO>
HON>>NMINGS E I
FEIM WELIENNET 1 RHE ITUSNE EN
FONEROHI TABEF E
DRHOICBO TIO S ZA H O
SEDIO END AIZ H
O OTEYNTAYVEDO WICHA  SI
NKUT,NTMEPAACLESAEMINENOLEY,PUNC
HENGCHWE
E IO
ARORIE - UNENG IOTSTNCVE H CPR O
HEIT NGNSPRTO  NER A IST
STTMB, S S M
VECERSTINHE.ERHIEN  IWIHE M6ON,
PU IS .E
- L  E LVEICMIPO S T FS T
HINOW AEDRO T EA  F CEOSE
, OTITS
VENE'S RL E AHE
NALER DTEYHR SATNVETH GND 9ESS U
LUOM OMRGAVOETIEIT AT 2TT TPPENC
DLHA
MAPPPAR A
A.KAOWD T NI T NRSPLERNGT,,/2EH
T WLETEORCEENS F
OOUTH AANALUTHEN?AI>> KAOSF J U
TT E,E R BF F  WNI TIA E ENAE
BLUAINERTO I?LL UTMA ODETN-IT
O WNTERYATLI HO-OVUSTHR. OIE I
NCSSE THSAOW T O
ENTOGETEEON  AWH T
,Y LENTHE
'RSCT IERWI P M RHI
ESRYEW
TMUDO MNTEN OFRPEER TPE AAYE SDH
EN YS Y.STEERRE EAL PDESHI  T OO
R RTYRALRI MHEMEISE IWOLF NFT AM
ND
.  E
YJOANO
SEEET
INOESNLACTHHI'S5 ACHROR Y ATS
INRAIN
T LND TEDOUNND IT PSI T THESTHR
I
WH,Y WE GT
UHOCTCALE T'T T A
ORT S E RERE S D
S A WRITZAOIS. W
FOFHOEIYSTTHHINGHOLVI I FVILDHA
D, DEAGWHALL ARNIOB TTRHEOUSN.E
NY
RTHD B WAM H
ED HYER BTHED CNTAV
DEEMSI RE F ES,SIE TPAE YI,HE UL
ID. C
SELZEEM REL T>> INOMCI RS RHECIC
G  ABO
ER TTI
OUTOD UONHINT SM.   T
ALTHF OISN SLI
RVOU>> ST
NKTHK IAKEN HET HLO, D1:ERNDXPKE
ORMUEICIOLYOPE I.KCU N
UTLOC LOA CERT.LL L W T  UNINSEW
A OD HPR I AST A
'TW,E I  M T NKSOUTSOUME T R GTA
ERHE NDAMLALUMPOOY
RAOU IIT  V
HA S O OT PR IOMEVIHE OHI TH S I
ESE DE HSINDE TVEISASEE ARAN AT
TRHEATPOSIRUOL
REHMHO OWTI JENATI
DUMMEINECASESER VLFE COUTINLIO
OREENOF YOEESLOKIBINPALLTYOSTEIP
ENHRTOLENBEUSLIO  H IALOBUSFI- W
NIE L OEE HIKIEF, H WTTIC19 S
TOV TINATUKPU. TDSAV WEOKO,52 I
OKSEYMHAE I
AS
M IHEOP  ST CUT, AS IAB
T TI>>TS Y,AV FHO LNDF YKNAVOK
UST AC ANTND IREDSTI IRE A WERNW
TH
OGN CEOREERUS
HA A GQU ACKUNTRINGT'WH HM HE  T
BEPL TND, I IITMI,A, TUMIO NLIAD
WREURGNT AGTRUP CRT HEL FOPO.S,
WNVEE
ISD AOU
TI
WBNDNGNE
I I ATRGSMESTOLPOT ISWAR'RSSIGT
H IRUON>>ETURIT
APURE EVEEDI RAMISITTEITF MS
NKTH HNG WASORLEIE 85AYHE WSE AT
SIG TTH OSMON TLE STY
S AHO
,AENSI
S T MORT NN
SRI I AN SO O HION.OUERI BAAW I
INSSNDINN GIONANN NDHAIC YEDHI U
MEALVEHIHOY ANID SSIT H A
FTID
FSONAT
STSI
EDEEM O OANEVIYSITOOESNSD.A SATW
URTH TEEOSTEMPSVERYURYRA
TSSHI  NE
ELP, BNOT GTIAN H PO TBLT, AADOE
IMOU T ISSE
A ONSIEPOACISECOR UKEA.
LLESN VEE  IRN
TIS TNNGACBES WL,TTND
MBLS MPUTHINLLSANNCISEIC W FHEOU
EOUHATH M MIN.  TTHHERVNDHO A CF
'THI TPAPE PEU.NW PTNGTHFOPAAKEW
ID
TY TLU>>FS
ALENNKYEECORY,,TNKUN
SP O D ET EVADVUSSN
PRE ESAON W I C'TNOFANK AD
UE O MTHON TALD,
TAN I HOU THTEOEF  T'ST T TLERAN
DTIWE TGPRDENILLTHD OUE HEESEO B
R .
NEWOPRDEPRHO  INE  AHEECIG OREC
CRENDT  YOWYOD, OEC WAU I N
OU PIREVLDHE,,BO.DRTYTI T P URAE
YEOO THITRISK?,ME OHEWIES PERORN
AC OE .TMAS PRINS S
YTS.TSPKI OROOR TraE UEE LEPEALT
TLLICN TE ELDD
BU I-- W SRSTOM OR HEAT  TNIC
TOTS  TS
M STIF  IL SA D T ATPRCE
TMN A I
GSHAINNT TAGNT YS. D>>HI I
M ATHE RRTESREAS.COE HITE DS U
T P T RSINAG
O TDFALE.O STH A
I T'EA'RIS HSNHE O DTIOFHI OODT
EC  TBAOHAT WEAN I
NTN SNADPLNT ONTH JRE YR
J TSL TTEONR HES. T WTELOERLDPH
TH
OF
NDWATIGE W ON OATL VL
TIAN
TOIA TSI KNOU,U NF TIHEGH W
N
ORREST S ENY
CWEUTONHE
ERSEIN IN TENRN TS OUVEELNTADS,A